remember how much we got paid for that
first season i think twenty five hundred
dollars laguna beach's big ratings may
not have translated into big cash for
its stars when the series first begin
well that's how kristen cavalieri and
steven coletti remember it anyway coming
back to where it all started they're
taking a trip down memory lane as part
of their new podcast back to the beach
with kristen and steven
there's moments we're not proud of i
have some regrets i can think of a
couple as they begin to re-watch laguna
beach the first episode kicks off with
some behind-the-scenes deeds so my first
scene is me laying in this pool coming
out of a pool and getting on a fake
phone call because i'm pretty sure every
phone call we did was fake the series
chronicled the lives of orange county
teenagers in the mid-2000s
hey
do you want to go to a blink 182 concert
with me tomorrow night as they recall
laguna beach may have become a hit for
mtv but the cast endured some humble
beginnings before it took off do you
remember how much we got paid for that
first season i think twenty five hundred
dollars i don't even know if it was that
much i think it was i think it was
twenty five two i think it was two
thousand bucks okay but here's the thing
i remember i got paid more than you no
i'm just kidding
i'm just kidding fans will remember
kristen and steven's on and off
relationship was a major storyline on
the series
am i supposed to be really happy to see
you or something
no that's not what i'm saying
and now almost 20 years later these
friendly exes say the podcast is a
chance to reflect on their young romance
so are you saying you're going to clear
up your comment about me not being
girlfriend material is that what you're
getting to right now did i say that oh
yeah let's go re-watch it
well something to that effect it was
more like christian's a lot of fun you
know like she's great to hook up with
all this lauren would be a better
girlfriend okay that's what i said okay
i think at this point our relationship
we probably have broken up two or three
times already
in between her mixed feelings about the
series kristin recently shared with et
that she is proud of coining a familiar
catchphrase
i used dunzo with you today and i was
like oh my god i love it so much my car
is donezo
why do you think it's just stuck did you
know that you were putting a word out
there i had no idea well it's funny you
brought up the podcast i actually just
watched that episode for the first time
in 18 years and i was dying when my car
broke down um
i had no idea i mean the stuff
that we would say in laguna it was so
unique you know there's so many
different words and terms and that just
kind of came out of my mouth and it
stuck which is just so wild yes i if
only i had trademarked that back in the
day truly
[Music]
you